hi I'm Ryan though right and Alyssa the
crazy Alyssa be cray-cray crazy so right
now I'm getting a slight boob graze by
Alyssa and it is awesome if you move I
will punch you in the face
this has been a highly requested trailer
it's another trailer for Batman Arkham
Knight Oh what's up where are they I
love that voice I can do all three
impressions my father was a drinker and
a fiend Joker Batman really whoa where
you must have friends yes I am bane
hello never so show me crazy
you never saw Dark Knight Rises I saw
actually I only other two I just never
got around to seeing
dude everyone agrees Dark Knight Rises
is the best one in the trilogy no no one
thinks that actually let's watch this
[ __ ] trailer I'm excited to see it
the first trailer was awesome that was
yeah it was Yahweh
watching this so late at night for you
guys we watch this trailer for you I
don't even do it for myself anymore
we don't sleep trailers it's real ha ha
ha you don't believe let's do this make
content can to help may contain card wow
that's beautiful
imagine this city
racist look how great everything looks
it's not such a big scale yeah amazing
you just got that's sweet nice good
chest wall oh it's all great yeah get a
Batman oh sweet is that Kevin Connor
nice that's good oh I was impressed by
his jumping Chinatown wow do you this
looks great
it looks amazing it looks like a
cinematic exactly like I stand by what I
said in the last trailer these graphics
are gonna be amazing I don't care how
they've done it it just looks
magnificent
dear dear there is no Savior Oh No so
good dude I wish they would just turn
this into a movie already it should all
play it first though it's so excited you
should at least make it like an animated
film be the Batman coming soon coming
soon when I want to know so you can get
it yeah reorder somehow you came for you
to play as Harley Quinn children Adam oh
damn look at those teeth oh this rack I
agree if I was a computer I would [ __ ]
her good to know
mmhmm yeah dude that game looks awesome
amazing it really does it looks like
more than just gameplay it looks like
hey we got some real awesome cinematic
effects going on that's why if you like
action if you like adventure to me it's
just like it covers so many different
categories that it's really something
that everyone's gonna like you'd if you
don't like Batman but I don't know who
doesn't like that me cuz it's awesome
it's Batman hello yeah I like how its
covering like just the whole city in
such a grand scope of things you know
it's like you got all these different
villains I'm sure you're gonna [ __ ]
around with but then you got the main
villain too and you're like who the [ __ ]
is this guy I love Heather incorporating
all the different villains in cuz I mean
what we saw obviously here's Harley
Quinn but there's the new guy there's
two face we saw in there know it's
pretty [ __ ] exciting I'm stoked for
this game I know you're are you gonna
play of course I'm gonna play it for
real for real for real he has this thing
where he says he's gonna play games and
I give him and then he doesn't enjoy one
game play it I will good are those of
you who like fable
I gave him people to play I give him two
and I'm gonna give him three but he
won't play it I have to film trailer
reactions that's why in those take up a
good ten minutes of my life every single
day and I think you guys are
recommending that trailer if you're on
you to the Chanel subscribe subscribe
dude oh oh man I want to [ __ ] play
that game all right
you look so good oh how could I forget
what shout out I'm sure cuz there's
always time in the day for shout out
there's always time in the day for shout
out hey JP stud muffin 93 he was polite
and he had an on-demand non-demanding
shout out request that's nice because
we're like I'm gonna kill you if you
don't give me a shout-out it's like yeah
wait do what how why do I want to give
you a shout-out now yeah I'm constantly
looking over my shoulder now
yeah constant there are so many people
are like four I'm scared man I'm afraid
someone's gonna kill me and then [ __ ] on
my corpse cuz you know they do that they
do that subscribers do that sometimes do
they do hell you never know what kind of
your back you don't know is out there
from all different countries you guys
but JP studmuffin 93 you were kind
enough to say it politely so thank you
here is your shout out to JP stud muffin
93 93 that was a good year it was a good
year I don't remember what happened that
year but I'm sure it was good mmm yeah
yeah yeah big show you said I'm his
favorite youtuber Oh
which I'm like aren't I everybody's God
like I haven't heard that one before no
I'm kidding I don't hear it often you're
awesome man for saying that thank you
hearing something like that just makes
my day big show
sure you got a big [ __ ] rock that [ __ ]
unless you're a girl then rock those big
titties but then if it was a girl but
what's done muffin work I mean I mean
clearly it would if it's he really ought
to Big Show Big Show right thanks show
I'm meaning an ass out of yourself now I
know I know this would be asked you need
to relax
that can help you relax I can um you
know put you to sleep in the nicest
possible way really relax your knees if
you know what I mean Jana Jana Braun
Dava I don't know if you're a girl or a
guy but you wanted to shout out so Jonna
if you're a girl you got an awesome
vagina regardless your name is awesome
yeah Jonna
if you're a boy you got a good uh
pimping onna the rain from I'm curious
to know where you're from because that's
a really cool name
that is a cool name yeah it rhymes Jonna
brand Ava [ __ ]
it's like rap rap you know what's funny
is like he can freestyle like no one's
business
but when he like tries to think about it
it's just a fall apart
only when I'm on camera I'm like Eminem
at the beginning of a mile I just choked
right away Johnna
you got a big vagina you come up here
and I will play this Roxie talking about
he was freestyling was he like David was
like freestyling non-stop I know and I'm
sitting over here thinking that you know
this is like something that he's
memorized because it was amazing and it
was like flawless and I asked him about
it he's like oh no this is just my
freestyling so I'm like what how's that
who does that
that's such serious talent he does it in
a way that is like really like I said
it's flows thank you that's really sweet
of you to say I'm going to do a
freestyling on camera one day and it's
gonna be awesome
thank you listen I didn't know you
thought that thank you oh gosh I can't
wait till we have sex it's gonna be
awesome
all right Alissa you got a nice-looking
I always wanna run everything with
vagina now listen you got a nice-looking
vagina
you got these really big titties they
make me just a little bit risky I want
to get up here and get a little bit
smiley I look into your face and I see
your beautiful eyes and I can't tell you
another light just because I want to get
in between your thighs oh come on that
was pretty good oh that's pretty good I
was I would've rhymed frisky with risky
frisky yeah what did I say smiley well I
like to go that was nice goodnight it's
okay
that's like to warm up to the warm up